foreign
[Music]
and I'm very pleased to be here today to
talk to you about covet testing the key
to the beginning middle and end of the
pandemic
professionally I'm managing director of
Bluestone Venture partners and health
Catalyst group but I'm very proud to be
a professor of practice and the
co-founder of the biomedical Diagnostics
program at Arizona State University an
advisor on covid to the Rockefeller
Foundation
today we're going to talk about covid
testing specifically Diagnostics role in
the pandemic and then covet in context
how does covet compare to the flu and
other epidemic and pandemic and then
we'll go back to the future where did
covet start and when will it end
let's start by looking at Diagnostics
role and the evolution of testing when
you see this I'm going to start with the
fact that how did testing begin it was
all about symptomatic testing lung CT
and bronchial lavage very very invasive
it moved from there to active disease
diagnosis where we are today with rtq
PCR and antibodies we then moved to
screening and as we look at screening
there are a number of key Technologies
PCR antigens crispr breath tests which
now there are one approved in the U.S
but also covet sniffing dogs and scratch
and sniff but what does the future look
like the future is all about
surveillance and the technology that is
most common today is Wastewater PCR and
NGS but I think in the future we'll also
be looking at air quality monitoring so
if we understand that where were these
tests happening it started in the
hospitals it moved to Central lab then
to point of care and ultimately as
everyone is very familiar with
particularly in the United States is
home and self-testing
so what are these Technologies as I said
it started with highly invasive
Technologies in an operating room with
the lungs moved to semi-invasive with
those nasopharyngeal swabs back of the
throat really the tickled the brain once
we moved to minimally invasive the front
of the nose and ultimately where we are
today is what I'll call passive with
breath and saliva testing
what about the price we have to follow
the money it started out with more than
a thousand went to hundredths now to
tens and then I think ultimately we'll
get to less than two dollars a test
so that gives you a sense of the
evolution of covet Diagnostics so what's
so important well Time After Time
whether it's the beginning middle or
towards the end we hope of the pandemic
everyone wants tests there are headlines
after headlines after headlines talking
about the fact that there are either not
enough tests or times too many tests so
what are these tests for for those in
the industry you all know this but what
we look for are the basics either the
viral element or the immune response do
I have active disease or did I mount an
immune response
at the beginning of the pandemic if you
had mounted an immune response we knew
you had had covet now with the
pervasiveness of vaccines we don't know
whether it's
immunity from the vaccine or immunity
from infection but those are the key
pieces of the system to understand the
tests that we have so how many tests do
we have out there well I'm very proud to
be the Principal investigator with a
team at Arizona State University
particularly Nate Wade he is the co-pi
and we have put together what we call
testingcommons.com and this I believe is
the largest database of covid tests in
the world it's not about how many tests
will come to that it's about what type
of tests are out there not just in the
United States but around the world and
not only tests that are there today but
tests that are being developed I look at
them and three different ways one is the
DX targets the red ones here are viral
tests and The Greener antibodies we then
look at platform rtpcr virtually all of
the viral RNA and then we look at
lateral flow and Elisa and where are
they coming from the United States other
parts of Asia and some from the EU but
let's delve into more details here so
you can understand where that is
happening
so when we look at that as I mentioned
it's in testingcommons.com so we look at
those 2 800 tests now let's break them
down into component parts
we currently have six major categories
of these tests from the ones that have
euas at the FDA the ones that are
laboratory developed tests the largest
category is ceibd we have ruo or
research use development and a category
that many many people forget are tests
that have actually had their eua revoked
so let's keep going and as they say peel
the onion here about these tests I'm
going to focus initially on the usfda EU
ways as you can see here the vast
majority of these tests are molecular of
that remember this number 88 or rtpcr we
have a few isothermal a little bit
sequencing and a little bit crisper
the next category are the antigen tests
in green and again remember those there
aren't a lot of them but they're playing
a critical role we then move on to
antibody tests so many of these were
approved early in the pandemic and then
when I call other which are collection
kits flu or RSV panels and patient
management again very few
so what the discussion is today in early
2022 or spring of 2022 is all about
these antigen tests so let's look at
them in more detail today there are 20
euas for over-the-counter covid
self-tests to give you a sense of what
it's like in Europe the over-the-counter
tests there are more than 40 of them but
in the U.S we have 20 of which three of
them are molecular tests these are all
lamp tests and can be done at home but
the vast majority and the cheapest ones
that are most affordable and most
available are the antigen tests
all but two of them are cereal for
asymptomatic so you have to do two tests
according to directions if you don't
have symptoms and one if you have
symptoms this gives you a sense of those
tests but role do they play and so many
people take a look at the CDC website or
the New York Times website and they look
at covet test volume it's very important
that when you look at covet test volume
that it's not just the gray line here
the gray at the bottom of this graph are
the reported PCR tests these are the
ones that the CDC the New York Times and
other places track however what I track
in addition to that are the antigen
tests and those done at home
little tougher to track for a lot of
reasons most part that the tests are not
reported to any health authorities and
only a small number even reported to the
doctor's offices however in looking at
this I believe that there are at least
four times if not five or more times
more home tests done today than
lab-based PCR so when you see those
numbers printed make sure you understand
is it total tests probably not is it
those lab-based PCR tests and why why
are these tests so important it's all
about timing you've probably seen this
chart by now but I'll add a few numbers
here which is typically if somebody's
Exposed on say zero they're not
infectious till day two or three even
with Omicron symptom onset may not
happen until day four or five
traditional results through a PCR lab
tests don't come out to do stay six or
seven by that point sixty percent of the
time that your infectious is already
behind you so it's key to use these home
tests I know there have been a number of
questions about home tests are they
accurate are they accurate enough this
is why it's important if you have any
doubts about those tests to do those
tests in a Serial fashion so that gives
you a quick summary of the home test but
what other kinds of testing modalities
are there
for schools the largest type of testing
is done by pooled sample and this gives
you a sense of all of the euas for
pooled sample there are two pulled on
the right where you see the number 12.
there are two tests that have an eua to
put 12 samples together there are four
that have ten two that have eight Etc
this is key because it gives everyone
the ability to get the test done very
quickly and a cost-effective manner with
a number of samples when we were in the
midst of an Omicron Surge and testing
was 30 to 40 percent positive not a good
place to be but for now it's ideal
so where are these tests coming from
let's look at the companies with the
largest number of euas you'll see on the
left Abbott has the most duas followed
by Siemens Roche and danaher but
underneath each column you can see what
the makeup of their euas are and how
many are in each of the different
categories either molecular antigen or
antibody or patient management so that
gives you a sense of it this was very
much focused on the U.S I'm going to go
now to show you what does it look like
in Europe and you see a different
perspective here where the antibody
tests are the most prevalent most of
these ceivd which is a
self-certification process were done
early in the pandemic about 37 percent
lateral flow 46 Eliza molecular is still
here but about 41 percent
rtpcr and you're a member for the euas
in the US it was about 88
PCR so very similar so this is all about
tasks that can be managed and marketed
what about the tests that have been
revoked and this is critical to
understand you remember the antibody
tests are in red what you see here is
almost 80 percent of all the tests that
have been revoked are antibody tests and
this is critical the FDA is authorized
about 250 antibody tests but 171 of them
are now on the do not use so when you
see an antibody test out there your
organization wants to use it it's
critical that you understand not just
that it got in the UA but that that eua
remains in effect
the other caution that the FDA gives us
are safety Communications and what you
can see here is there are a number of
safety Communications I won't go through
all of them but again very important and
this is often overlooked to look up the
safety Communications the warning
letters sometimes they're about
individual companies and sometimes like
on the right safety Communications you
have warning letters about companies but
sometimes they're about just practices
like antibody testing self-testing rapid
antigen testing and variance so this is
a key piece of the sda's approach and
important to keep up with this on a
regular basis
so again we've looked at the core here
but this is mostly U.S focused today
what about the future I think it's
important to look at the test and
development not just in the U.S but
around the world and remember we talked
about molecular that PCR was 88 to 90
percent of all tests well when you look
at the future you see a very different
view where PCR is only 40 percent and
now you see isothermal which is mostly
lamp crispr and sequencing come into
about 30 percent of new technologies and
I'll spend a minute now and talking
about those new technologies you also
see fewer new tests coming into the
antibody area where I think we have
plenty of antibody tests out there so
just to remind you what are we looking
for in these tests viral elements or
immune response
you probably are familiar with the fact
that we have a lot of technology for the
viral RNA and viral antigen tests and
immunoassays the most important change
in these tests is that they became
automated in central lab and then became
smaller by going to a DIY finger stick
less blood less saliva less nasal fluids
into the small test
that's the state of the art in viral RNA
and immunoassays but what's the state of
the art in surveillance
that's all about waste water and this
looks at just one example of Wastewater
analysis
that was thought of as new this is
actually early in the pandemic but I use
it because it shows how dramatically
effective Wastewater can be as a
surveillance tool the first five bars
here and this is in Tempe Arizona or
during the lockdown and what you could
see is virtually no no change this is
the zero level of covid-19 in the
Wastewater just one week after lockdown
ends you start to see covid-19 in the
waist right after that more and by four
weeks later you see covet in the
Wastewater in five out of six districts
so this can be a highly highly effective
approach to Wastewater and that's
critical to understand but where do we
go from here what other new technologies
are there
so if we look at that I believe that we
will see more and more new technology
happen and it's not just about getting
to
smaller and smaller it's also about
simplifying the technology integrating
it and miniaturizing it the best example
here is traditional PCR one of the
biggest challenges is the temperature
cycling and the thought that that had to
happen in a large instrument
but with unique cooling Technologies
we've found that you can make those very
small into a portable system or even a
handheld disposable system this is a
system that has an eua for a point of
care use we're seeing that in isothermal
as well it's quicker than PCR but has
lower sensitivity
so where else will we go with our
technology
um what you will see here is on
sequencing technology sequencing
technology itself has changed way before
the pandemic to go from huge systems to
benchtop systems but I think we will see
new technologies here or we might even
have a handheld NGS system through an
electro sensing system it's an hour and
a half to resolve but think about it it
was 20 years ago that it took a
tremendous amount of equipment to do
this and now we might be able to do it
in just an hour and a half in a handheld
unit
but what about radically different
Technologies if we look at these
Technologies I think they come in three
pieces one is mass mass spectross mass
spectrometry which is a protein
fingerprint no sample prep needed you
can use whole blood and we're looking at
positive charged DNA fragments no
reagents and
um can be something that virtually every
lab knows how to do
we can also look at tetrahsic citation a
chemical fingerprint to be used with the
throat swab or breathalyzer transferred
to a glass Slide the process here in
terms of sample presence is more
complicated but it's just two minutes to
resolve
and lastly MRI technology again very
widely known here again no sample prep
two hours per quart cartridge you can
probably do about 60 samples a day in
one unit these are the technologies that
I suspect we will see much more of in
the future
so if we take that where else can we see
these radically different Technologies
it's an AI and when we look at AI I'm
going to start with Airborne particle
detection this is key
so there are two different ways to do it
one is the room pathogens and the other
is breath viral sampling
but the thing that has changed most
recently is there is now an eua for a
VOC test volatile organic compounds
where you breathe into a unit and get
your answers very quickly so challenges
false positives and false negatives like
all sorts of other tests but still
um a great breakthrough for this next
stage where we may be we may be testing
a lot of people and we want to do that
in the shortest possible period of time
what else could we see well maybe it's
on your watch
you have a skin detection and a
biometric indicators of infection but
not there yet but I believe through
electrochemical sensing and through
Imaging we will make these Technologies
work they're working for hard conditions
I believe ultimately we will see them
for infectious disease but not today
so I gave you some examples of where the
technology is going but let's step back
a bit and look at the challenges around
tests and I'm going to say it's three
areas number one the boom and bust cycle
we don't have time to go through that
but I'm sure you're aware of the fact
that we had no tests everybody ramps up
and now there seem to be extra tests we
need to diversify Supply we now have 17
different antigen home manufacturers
which is great
if this is something that goes on for
years do we need more of those to have
healthy competition and lower the price
everybody looks at it differently but I
think that having a diversification of
supply and supply chain is critical
technology must keep going forward
better faster and hopefully more
affordable and we need to ensure that
that affordability happens with better
distribution not just for those who can
afford to buy the tests
next is an area that there's been much
discussion which is consistent Public
Health reporting I talked earlier about
the fact that these home tests as you
can see on the second sub bullet here
reporting is basically non-existent so I
don't know if you've done a home test
most of you probably have done one or
more what do you do with that result if
you're positive you might call your
doctor but not in every in every state
there is not a required
system for that doctor to report the
positives what if you're negative
those are not being reported try calling
your public health office they don't
have the time or technology or staff to
record people individually and then when
we look at Public Health reporting do we
have one National system we don't we
have 50 or more systems on public health
so that's another challenge
but lastly is the area that we've
share a few slides on this which is
variance what is the variance well since
well basically it's a virus fighting
back the virus wants to survive and by
doing it it knows it needs to change so
we need to track those variants and we
need to understand whether the tests
work with them so let me share a little
bit about this we know the challenge of
covet is about waves of disease we got
down in the U.S to less than 10 000
cases a day and today we're celebrating
with only 50 000 cases it's all about
these waves and when we were in June
2021 that's when we were down under 10
000 cases a day and Delta and Omicron
were still to come so we can't take this
for granted so what is a mutation you're
probably aware of this now but for the
few more aren't
um we know that an mRNA strand is almost
30 000 bases long and that if one or two
changes happen to code
um it does not change the coding of this
protein but if you start seeing multiple
changes one of three things happen
one is it's so few it's just a variance
of notes it does not change severity
virulence or mortality
we then move into a variant of Interest
where it starts to change and then we
know what the who
calls the variance of concern where
there are proven data that shows this
has an effect on patient and it could be
infectiousness virulence severity or
mortality it becomes a variant of
concern well what does the U.S look like
well if we go back to 2020 you see this
original strain in Gray on the left hand
side of the chart there were very few
mutations and we might have gotten a
little bit too comfortable with that we
then saw Alpha and Alpha became the
dominant strain in 12 weeks and we
thought that was fast then Delta
happened Delta became the dominant
strain in green here Alpha in red here
um the dominant strain in four weeks oh
my goodness and we thought that was fast
then came home across and it was so
contagious it became more than 50
percent the dominant strain and purple
here in just two weeks so when we have a
mutation the question is what do we need
to know we need to know does it make
tests less accurate increase cases
increase deaths
make tests ineffective and doesn't in
fact impact uh effect the vaccine
likelihood of protecting you we now know
a lot more about Omicron and reality is
um it does make some of the tests like
less accurate but just a few and why do
I say it doesn't increase deaths it's
because the death rate for Omicron in
particular has gone down the number of
deaths have gone off is a number of
cases have gone up however the percent
of deaths have gone down and why was
almost crime so scary well all the rest
Alpha and beta and Delta all came from
the same original Source but all of a
sudden Omicron came very different and
looked more like Alpha and beta than
just a new variant of Delta
so it was important to understand
where covet came from to understand
where Omicron came from I won't go
through this in detail but what you can
see is it's critical to understand that
it came from and will start
with this slide
is the wet market and hornan and what we
see is there are two markets The Market
East of the market West and virtually
all of the cases came from right near
the wild animal section in the Market
West this was key into understanding
that and what was also key is to know
that where it started and where it went
to and what we can trace not perfectly
but we can't trace the difference
between where it went from a bath to
some unknown location to then within the
market the challenge here was what
looked like a reasonable decision at the
time is that the market was thoroughly
disinfected and it was until two months
later that we really understood those in
China that it was important to
understand that host in between the
original bat Reservoir over to the
market and to humans but from there we
can trace exactly what the lineage is
and the importance of international
spread
so when you talk about International
spread I think it's important to
understand how does covid compare to
other epidemics or pandemics and it'll
take you a little while to look at this
chart but what you can see is here we
are today with Omicron where the death
rate is relatively low but the
transmissibility or the are not is
relatively high and we've moved from
covet Wuhan to covet Delta to here we
are in coveted Omicron but where we
don't want to go is here where you have
norovirus and measles and bumps where
they are highly highly contagious even
more contagious than we have today
so what that brings me to is when people
say this they say yeah yeah the cold is
contagious too the flu is contagious so
let's compare covid to the flu and given
where we are now I compare covid to the
flu across two seasons
and briefly
coven about 80 million plus the flu two
seasons 91 million Hospital admissions
covid is three times bigger than the flu
and the typical time in the hospital is
twice as long as the flu in terms of
deaths this is so sad I get emotional
about this I have five members of my
family and friends who have died almost
a million people where the flu is a
hundred thousand and this is two flu
seasons and the death rate across the
entire pandemic and I know people say
Omicron is just like the flu it is still
four times higher than the flu but if we
look across the whole pandemic what we
see is uh covid is 10 times higher and
why is this important well it's
important because as challenging as that
is broadly it's been disproportionately
challenging to groups of color and many
minority communities including black
Hispanic and Asian communities and the
U.S has a higher death rate
than and number of years lost than any
other country in in the world but what
we know is covet is not one disease so
as I summarize here I want to emphasize
that there are still covid we talk about
as one disease but we know that it does
not hit everybody in the same way we
know that at least 20 percent of people
I believe even more than that are indeed
completely asymptomatic and they have
the ability to spread and there are life
six different kinds of covet and or
clusters of covet and as it moves
further I suspect there will be more
than these six you can read on the slide
as to
um the severity here the first three are
less severe
excuse me and the last three are more
severe
so if that gives you an overview of
covid where do we go from here
number one I think that there's going to
be a normalization of covet in 2022
we're starting to see that now most
importantly is on the top bullet here
individual health versus covet Health
from mandates to protection of the
vulnerable and I hope vaccines will be
available for all ages hopefully by
mid-year
there's going to be an expansion of the
workplace role for covet protection and
for for health expansion of patient
direct role with tests being done at
home
and when we talk about public health I
don't know I don't know whether it's
going to be expansion or contraction but
we will see changes to date we saw this
huge expansion of the role of Public
Health but a lot of our society work
against that and say it should not and
it should contract from now
so overall the future imperatives that I
see is the covet testing and future
vaccinations I believe like flu will
move to the workplace
telemedicine is fully integrated partly
because of the red box here which is
self-testing becomes
um standard and lastly and I'm going to
cross my fingers here and hope that we
have lessons learned from this pandemic
and that we use those lessons for public
health and individual health for the
future so we can do better as we move
forward
so with that let me say thank you
um and feel free to be in touch
um with me and happy to um follow up and
uh stay safe everybody stay well
thank you